Hey everybody, it's Mike from Orderflows
here and want to talk about uh the
ultrabond contract and the order flow
that you see in there. You know, there's
so many different contracts, futures
contracts that traders can trade and a
question I get asked a lot is, you know,
what's the best market to trade with
orderflow? And while there's no best
market, you know, I really believe that
there's a best market for you, just as
there's no perfect chart type, you know,
there's there's so many different types
of charts that are available to traders.
um you know there's time based tickbased
uh reversal bar you know hyanashi
there's so many different charts I'm not
saying you know which one is better than
the other or one market is better than
the other it really comes down to
understanding you as a trader um you
know your risk profile
um you know your ability to read the
markets and and what's taking place and
you know I've always found uh bonds and
and ultra bonds you know the interest
rates on on the CBBOT to be uh very
easily read in the order flow Because
generally speaking, you know, you don't
get the erratic movements that you get
in the stock indices or even now in the
metals like gold and silver. It's it's,
you know, markets has a lot of
volatility because, you know, there's a
lot of price discovery going on and
there's a lot of searching for volume in
the market where traders can transact uh
decent volumes. you know, in a market
like uh bonds, ultra bonds, 10ens, ultra
10s, um you know, there's good size. So,
you don't get those erratic moves where
the market is really looking for uh
volume to trade because the the depth of
the market in those uh interest rates
tend to be pretty solid and it's it's a
very liquid market. So, ultra bonds, why
do I like ultra bonds is because, you
know, I have sort of a a
handful of trades that are burned into
my brain that anytime I see them, it's
just an automatic trade. And again, the
reason why I like market like ultra
bonds is because my setups happen in
there uh several times a day. Okay?
Okay, I don't need them happening every
5 minutes or something, but uh you know,
I just need them happening uh often
enough that it makes it worthwhile to to
follow those markets. And you know,
today in the ultra bounds is perfect
example. We're right here at the low of
the day and we have a ratio and
divergence, right? Now, an orderflow
ratio, what it is is it's it measures
the order flow at the bottom of green
candles or the top of red candles. And
if it's bullish, it'll print the number
here like 131. Here's 80. Um, you know,
here's a bearish 133.3. Here's a bearish
159.3.
And then with a divergence. Okay, what
is a divergence? Is it's a new or equal
low with positive delta. Delta in order
flow is a net difference between
aggressive buying and aggressive
selling. Okay, so if you have positive
delta, then you have net aggressive
buying. And and what why that's
important at the low of the day is
because well you have net positive uh
aggressive buying at the low. So you
know that aggressive traders have
stepped in to sort of identify this as
being a low in the market that they're
interested in that they're they're
willing to start buying aggressively.
Okay. Now just because you have positive
delta at a low to me isn't isn't enough,
right? You need something a little bit
more than that. And that's why I like
using the order flows ratios. Um it's a
calculation that I devised, you know, a
long time ago to just sort of help me
understand what's taking place at the
bottom of a bar. And if I have a a
number that's blue underneath the bar,
like here 131, it's telling me there's
price exhaustion taking place at the
bottom of this bar. And then when you
couple it with aggressive buying coming
in, what it's telling me is that, hey,
you know what? We have a potential
reversal taking place. The market is
selling off, making new lows. made new
lows. Okay. But what's taking place in
the order flow, right, is we're starting
to see a form of price exhaustion take
place. That's how can I tell because I I
I've got the 131 here. So, it's telling
me um based on the number that there is
exhaustion in the market, plus
I have aggressive buying coming in. So,
I have aggressive selling showing signs
of exhaustion. add to it aggressive
buying coming in because you know that's
what moves the market is the aggressive
trading either the aggressive selling is
going to move the market down and
aggressive buying is going to move the
market up. But if I have a sign in the
order flow
that aggressive selling is weakening.
How do I know it's weakening is because
I have a sign of exhaustion. If I have
exhaustion taking place then I know it's
weakened. Follow that up with aggressive
buying coming in. So the aggressive
selling is getting uh weaker and you add
to it that aggressive buying is coming
in getting stronger. Okay. So you know
imagine that you got the selling
weakening buying strengthening. That's a
good sign for potential reversal and you
have it right here. This is a nice
bullish reversal and the market moves
from basically around the 24 area up to
the 1204 area. Now the opposite. Let me
show you an example of uh I think we had
a
do we got a bearish one here? Yeah,
right here. Okay, now this is a little
bit different. Okay, I mean we have one
here. This is on the reopen the other
day. Um we rallied up to the high around
uh 7:00.
So you had a bullish divergence
right here, the new low with positive
delta 154 with the bullish ratio of zero
because you had a zero down here. So,
it's just going to kick off a zero. But
up here, you also have a bearish
divergence,
okay? Because you got negative delta at
the high, right? You had negative delta
at the high. What's that's telling you
is aggressive sellers have stepped in at
the high of the day. And that's
important. You're at your high of the
day. What do you expect to see? You
know, a market in motion should
generally keep going in that direction
until what happens? A couple things can
happen. You know, the aggressive buying
can weaken.
Aggressive selling starts coming in. You
could run into exhaustion or you could
run into price defense. And what we have
up here is actually price defense. You
see this ratio, it's a bearish ratio. 05
0.05
is telling me that there is instead of
exhaustion, what we have is price
defense. That means it's a very small
number. Okay. So, in the order flows uh
trader software, let me just show you
really quick here how we um use this
just come get up the settings coming up
here and okay so
your orderflow ratios okay so price
exhaustion is a number 30 and above
what we call ratio bonds high price
defense is 0.69 69 to zero. It can't be
negative. So if it's 69 or below, then
we have price defense. This number up
here 05
is telling me it's price defense. It's a
number below
69. 0.69.
Okay. If it was above 30, 30 and above,
that's going to be price exhaustion,
right? So this next number here is 35.
So tell me there's price exhaustion at
the top of this bar. All right. So,
we've got here. So, we've got um price
defense. Right now, I treat price
defense and price exhaustion at swing
highs and swing lows almost the same,
even though they're sort of on opposite
spectrums because it is a potential
reversal point for me. Okay. Price
defense. Obviously, if someone's
defending a price, the price shouldn't
go any higher. And if you have price
exhaustion, same thing. Price shouldn't
go any higher if it's going up. if you
have price exhaustion being exhibited.
But when you combine that, the ratios,
right, all I'm really caring about is is
there a ratio? Is there a red number
above the red candle? That's telling me
that's a bearish ratio. Just as if there
was a blue number below the green
candle, that tell me that's a bullish
ratio. So you got the bullish runs up to
the bearish. So I got price defense,
right? So I got my order flows ratio
plus
plus divergence, right? the aggressive
selling coming in at the high and we
start selling off down into new lows and
new lows and new lows. Okay. So, you
know that that's why I like markets like
ultra bonds is simply because you know
you don't get these erratic
moves that you see in other markets like
gold and silver right now in markets
like NASDAQ and and even e- minis right
you know e- minis
is a difficult market for some traders
to trade simply because you know you're
moving six seven eight handles
very quickly. Why? Because the market is
trying to perform price discovery. It's
looking for volume to transact. When
you're trading in a market that trades a
lot of volume, interest rates at price
levels. I mean, you know, this is even
in the middle of the night, you know,
this is 7:00 at night. You're trading a
thousand contracts per price level. Now,
this is a four range chart. I do believe
that uh for me for my the way I that I
trade a rangebased chart in interest
rates serves me best because it helps me
understand what's taking place in the
order flow. And you can see like during
the normal session, you know, you're
getting several thousand contracts
at a price level. Okay? So there is that
liquidity. So, you're not going to have
those quick crazy moves that you often
see in other contracts that lack that
deep liquidity at price as the market is
searching um to transact volume. Okay.
And you know, so the the divergence and
ratio is is one of my breadandut trades.
You know, if you've been following my
channel for any period of time, you know
that that is something that I've always
talked about going back 10 years, okay?
And it's something that I can see in
interest rates, you know, fairly
regularly. I see it in in all markets,
but, you know, in interest rates
especially, I like to see them. Okay.
So, you know, in the next video, I'll
talk about some of my other favorite
trades. You know, I can just see a few
coming in right here. you know, there's
a bearish one here, bearish one here,
here. Um, but we'll talk about those in
a different video. So, thanks for
watching this video and I'll see you
guys in the next one.